según responde tiro por tiro acción
durante casi 10 minutos siete misiles
quiera superficie del ejército
surcoreano y un misil estadounidense
fueron lanzados al mar de japón un
ejercicio militar con sabor a
advertencia el día después de una prueba
de 8 misiles por parte de corea del
norte
la amenaza nuclear y los misiles de
corea del norte están cada vez más
avanzados recientemente ha disparado
varios misiles balísticos
y programas nucleares y de misiles de
corea del norte son una amenaza para la
paz de la península coreana el noreste
de asia y el mundo regional luego y
silva el nuevo presidente surcoreano
hyun song y all pretende ser más firme
que su predecesor con el vecino del
norte tras cinco años de interrupciones
los lanzamientos combinados entre corea
del sur y eeuu se reanudaron este año
este último lanzamiento es el segundo
desde enero hace unos días se celebraron
unas maniobras conjuntas entre las dos
armadas con la presencia del
portaaviones nuclear ronald regan
procedente de japón el objetivo era
demostrar que existe una vigilancia
total ante las acciones de unión los dos
aliados están preocupados según su
información corea del norte está
acelerando la modernización de su
ejército el país incluso estaría
planeando una nueva prueba nuclear de
concretarse esta sería la séptima prueba
realizada por el régimen de kim jong-il